all right you want to we want to do
blood and gold sure all right I'll put
bots in this time in this one two random
people will be the Sharks and then for
divers oh I am a shark okay the two
people who are the best at the SHA all
right what should I be Bob what are you
gonna be
I like the mako or the tiger usually I'm
gonna go for the great white just for
scaring dad you you be the aggressor and
I will be your little companion who are
you now rule gotcha all signs point to
us losing badly so I have faith you know
what you've got my hard bots on your
cell we have art never buy we won you
got hard but the boss of this game are
up third are they funny it's a hard box
shark
oh no oh hey buckle up I still have
nightmares I'm not play this game in
years these bots are already like aiming
at you guys yeah no they're not all you
think sorry buddy how's it going friend
hey buddy
the one thing that stuff about this is I
really don't know these maps anymore
so as the shark it's hard to exploit all
the little side alleys and stuff if you
don't know the maps very well I don't
know I never do the masseter please this
game enough oh there's a flare whoa oh
oh there sharks in here already hey guys
well I guess the boss the Royal treasure
that healthy you own money yeah okay oh
oh I got him marks that was you how many
dead huh your friends dead I'd yeah you
know like a loser I felt lost shitsnacks
I felt like dying you know this I didn't
want to give him like too much of a
skier I'm a pretty spooky shark when you
get to know me like right about now can
you kill him a second earlier I was
trying to repair Steve he's wounded he
need a spine is a robot I'm a living
person yeah well why should I be your
life over Steve
here he's got a lot fraud see ya wait
why didn't you help me out I'm sorry I
was busy
it's okay Steve I'm here for you don't
worry about it
oh you're with Steve are you I don't
know Eve huh ah that's interesting that
you're with Steve collecting so much
treasure oh hey how's it going OSH oh
you're doing Bob let's let's coordinate
I come in like a juggernaut oh and then
you'll you'll smack them up side the met
frickin head alright I see you I feel
you you feel me you feel me bro heal you
bro
you feel me thank you actually really do
oh by myself oh dear now horrible things
simply happen you know oh no oh no oh no
you all yeah I'm dead I'm gone wow yeah
they're coming for you wait oh my god
yeah that box
what about it guys about on it's
ridiculous maybe you guys should go eat
something else and leave the people
alone maybe you guys should shut up and
just be right for that I could go eat
something else yeah I could eat some
people aren't food for shark I could
[ __ ] season one ish what dude
what nothing oh okay oh there's screwy
with it oh no who's screwing with you I
don't think anyone's screwing with you
don't worry Wade we're gonna be fine
we're gonna be just fine
okay he just I mean you're gonna die but
I'll be fine
deep breaths under Wow well so we're not
going to be fine we're gonna be just
buddy oh no [ __ ] blocks man yeah
they're good wait new plan
we're gonna take the shark corpse and
we're gonna drag it along with us as a
warning sign okay all right all right
I'm pushing it along
what's up a penis this is your shark
friend the guy eaten or shot killed now
we're going to eat them later
well okay Steve summative funtime just
pushing the shark corpse along woo whoa
hey there you are
hey that's water where you be your ID
hey buddy
oh holy oh what a loss I don't
understand I don't understand I don't
get it guys I understand I don't
understand
hey guys you in here how's it going
fellers oh okay whoa whoa that is
vicious you just go through the water
and come on live human oh wait actually
killed me for once it wasn't your boat's
just carrying you Wow yeah that's that's
what I'm talking with I've done a lot of
damage they just always take the credit
for my kills
all right shark or two in my day sorry
we're we're winning this war of
attrition no big deal true you are
winning that okay I'm going I'm gonna go
in Bob I'm goin in all right oh come on
oh where I'll be you we're all getting
me T right next to you if you just
wanted to know I'm I cannot sleep I
cannot dream I can't dream you like a
[ __ ] dead Oh Adam who wanted to be my
friend I don't I'll pass
okay sound bag I did it
man I can't uh I need to see my armoire
because I'm not able to say you got a
better harder man yeah fresh the [ __ ]
out of them
I'm gonna I'm gonna thrash the [ __ ] out
of them right about now oh never mind
ah God I'm pressing so hard I feel like
I'm killing all the Sharks wait I can't
carry the team like Ethan has some
pretty strong opinions about how your
contributions are going with ya weed
she's just good I don't get the final
hit on half of these things doesn't mean
I'm not helping yeah I like ya keep it
up yeah Ethan what else has Wade done to
wrong you in this department yeah Oh God
miss right and God you put each compared
to my you finishing me off like a half
dead body you should come hang out with
yeah you guys should go get treasure
fridge ready yeah red shirt red left all
the treasurer oh there is why your
sister fast ow
god damn oh whoa I can't keep up with
you we're a little quick angry you're
quick swimmers we are oh yeah feels what
you come here hey at one point in life
we were the fastest swimmers ha ha ha
yeah it's a firm joke thank you for
clarifying for me just wanted to make
sure everyone was aware where are you
[ __ ] be gotta be careful we're ahead
but yeah yeah I miss I miss I miss I got
out well okay I was already basically
dead yeah you were pretty good yeah [ __ ]
like good those guns are doing it with
your pops around huh yeah the doing good
how are they used not really huh ha ha
ha ha ha I'm shat hey I got a new view
time ok my life I just be careful Bob be
careful be wise
not wise I changed my mind word to the
one wise we're our ball
oh there you are hi that works that were
that was good Bob no good the double
distraction yeah what they were looking
away with much easier
where you at [ __ ] yeah we're you guys
grazie we're at [ __ ] bags Oh being out
in the open water hang out me open with
a bath Oh
goddamn it I can't [ __ ] it anything i
suck suck so hard
nice back sex I got fat - okay well we
know that mark okay hearing me it's okay
no it's cool
Bob you're doing great you just gotta
believe in the heart of the you I found
a totem I believe in the heart of my boo
yeah that was the best yeah that's it no
nothing's happening and I'm happening
yeah I think we're fine I'll know what
you're told no one is breaking anything
so don't worry I'm not so just continue
doing whatever is that you're doing
currently and it's fine I've got a plan
that point about how urgent watch what I
say
mmm yes [ __ ] oh damn oh [ __ ] [ __ ] we
get him get him Bob get him Bob they're
out of tickets there are two tickets we
got to go go go go go get the cage get
him get him get him get him I'm going oh
[Music]
I'm so far away
no watch me Gary look at how my carrying
even your back sore from all that are
you okay
what there you go yeah man I mean [ __ ]
huh you're welcome he had 28 death yeah
I gotta I gotta go I gotta go take a
shower because I am sweaty
us borgen's too hard black shark to
prelada
okay we I broke we can I can select
divert all right I think if we also like
divert how do you do that if you go to
private match everyone on diver yep okay
and Boop wait hold on wait oh okay can't
I have some things come about wait where
do you a second popped up con where do I
go to private match play private match
you are you there's four bars that say
quick match match making private
matching tutorial on the left side of
the screen once you click the big play
button on top that's not here go back to
main menu Ethan kick return to menu oh
oh yeah I got it I got what are you
doing I am out in the car first all
right are you diver click private match
click the big picture get your acne out
of your ear okay okay everyone's diving
oh hey cool where you worked okay yeah
we're gonna die aren't we we're gonna
die now we're fine so hard bots are bad
right if that's like the highest
difficulty I remember them yeah yeah I
think it is oh okay I just want to [ __ ]
when you want to let you hurt me P I'm
sorry you go you're not supposed to [ __ ]
the shark now we're know welcome right
no no I can kill them yeah [ __ ] kill
them no not a [ __ ] man kill them
[ __ ] no them [ __ ] kill them
[ __ ] them to death that's not true I
mean I was like doing how do you even do
that to a shark but I guess it makes
more sense have you been doing that the
whole time yeah have you done
[ __ ] the shark that is that wrong oh
yeah I got if it feels right I mean even
if it feels right I'll just really feel
right but I just thought that was the
whole thing we were here doing Oh
oh my god okay whoa oh my god holy head
of the shark dawn whoa whoa what about
the other one like yeah so or whatever
oh my god damn holder oh yeah
okay got one of them to Jesus Wow ah
[ __ ] they never [ __ ] go away no they
do not gone you killed me it spawned
whoa [ __ ] [ __ ] oh god I just put it
up right there guys I think we're
literally no no no no no dude everybody
focus everybody stick together don't go
on your own we got this okay keep going
around
oh I got oh yeah oh yeah yeah okay Bobby
you got a rocking technique is it
working yeah this isn't totally
different this is completely different
than it's been so far oh god yo when you
were I got I got you
oh no I I didn't know when you were
[ __ ] on me before so I laughs OH
i damaged it where the [ __ ] did it go
it's right in front of me oh my god oh
my god oh my god
that says great white I don't know where
you guys are
I've lost everybody I see you can I
speak you okay you're all I see is
anyone else actually collecting gold
yeah I am bar I'm not I am I lose
walking bleeding mark you're bleeding
sorry
get out of here get out of here bleeder
swim into the open ocean but don't be
near us guys I just want a friendly hug
it'll make me fun Oh God hey Tommy it's
on me see my fault guys mark if you look
here less you see where you can see
nothing swim in that direction
no guys I'm fine you guys are just you
guys could have killed him a little bit
sooner that would have been great this
is fine me now I'm here I'm here
yeah I'm dying oh oh oh I just want I
just wanna just oh my god it's so hard
to get you there so fast oh whoa oh oh
oh God I'm a professional good [ __ ] Wade
you did it Wade we believed in you the
whole time
I believe so badly okay get the [ __ ] out
of here Wade I must remind I'm under
that whoa God that was so close oh oh
it's coming it's coming
oh oh I got him story
we got like I caught him I shot him I
shot him Oh together mo may I have this
board oh okay I'm wounded you gotta find
em Oh Wade there's ammo boxes around oh
there's help too hello I'm just swimming
and bleeding in the I heard the Sharky I
heard of sharks near night near me near
me near me oh [ __ ] there's the other yes
I stabbed it to death Oh God about my me
where to go where to go where to go
where to go where to go I mean I told
her I blasted it whoa oh you're dead
[ __ ]
have the same gun that's awesome okay
all right okay all right okay I'm gonna
back into a corner probably the best
strategy right now okay where are they
I'm so scared now they're not out the
same door I'm watching a bunch of
treasure up here got my night-vision
scope on I'm watching it they're coming
in coming in front door front door and I
see in my family
where's the other one where's the other
one all the other ones inside inside out
inside outside exactly I got him I'm
sniping from above you're good good good
that's good that's good we're doing
great I'm gonna keep watching out here
with my night vision I got my 10 spear
gun Oh for some bees are shown above
above above Oh God William I am I hit
him again oh I'm alive oh that didn't go
as planned
oh I hit up I am oh [ __ ] stop Oh
oh my god shirks gotta be low here to me
I killed him okay I had shooted him you
did I saw it was you got tons of lives
left
uh-huh oh well there's one down oh yeah
why doesn't it volley gun kill him in
one go it seems like ah oh I see I know
Oh Oh God oh [ __ ] Amy we're inside
outside that's right that's like okay
okay okay Dorgan right outside looks
like we're good okay we got no life left
oh [ __ ] oh boy that's not good they just
attacked my dead body
oh no that was you I'm just watching you
oh it's wait who is that I came
oh my god wave you can do it
wait you'll win this you got it only one
more stop wait and then on the way back
oh wow
dark Swan file not moving well oh my god
why didn't one day oh yeah we were
we're almost there because of me but
wait wait and Bob and mark you guys
[ __ ] it up we'd really [ __ ] it up at
the end they're like we were all
watching no one has the assists that you
do ya know what he has right now
[Music]